on
my
oh
erasmus can educate perhaps to
evolve in a kind of
European openness I am French I
smell of games German Spanish
[Music]
I build as a father as
a husband as as
business manager and
I had the opportunity to do an
exchange for a year I don't even know
who
the ia erasmus of experience was cut canton
medical with the family so we were
completely lost
[Music]
the races no longer also l  interest is to
see what it is another life another
country another
culture  culture what in
all good honor date a remake
I was lucky if I met I
met my wife at that time so
I'm lucky and she followed me
behind and that at the end of  20 of 15 years
in france in ireland income
brings back the whole family woman child the
dog e  t we leave somewhere else
[Music]
excerpts